this morning we're introducing you to an
army officer turned paralympian in 2004
melissa stockwell became the first
female american soldier to lose a limb
in the iraq war just four years later
she was the first veteran of that
conflict to qualify for the paralympic
games cbs this morning saturday co-host
dana jacobson recently met stockwell at
the u.s olympic and paralympic museum in
colorado springs they discussed her
journey to tokyo and what it means to be
part of team usa
i get asked a lot how'd you end up in
the army
short and sweet i love our country
melissa stockwell was a second
lieutenant in the u.s army's
transportation corps when she deployed
to iraq in march of 2004
three weeks later within seconds the
entire trajectory of her life changed we
were going into central baghdad and we
left the gate that morning and i was in
a vehicle a humvee that had five of us
soldiers in it about 10 minutes into
that convoy we went under this bridge
and there was just this deafening i mean
boom and there's black smoke and there's
smell of metal and the windshields
crashed in and our vehicle is like
swerving to the left and be ricochet of
a guard rail
to make a long story pretty short and
that roadside bomb that we hit did take
my left leg above the knee it was gone
it was severed immediately and
thankfully there was a combat medic a
few vehicles back who knew i was hurt
pulled me out of the vehicle put a
tourniquet on and really saved my life
stockwell was 24 years old and soon
found herself at walter reed army
medical center among a sea of wounded
veterans and i remember getting there
and i looked around and i saw soldiers
who were missing both legs they had a
leg and an arm missing they had lost
their eyesight and i thought holy cow am
i lucky i mean all i lost was one leg i
thought you were lucky i was a lucky one
i had three good limbs my mind my i had
my life so i'm kind of
accepting the loss of my leg very early
on because i mean talk about perspective
once an athletic kid who dreamt of going
to the olympics as a gymnast stockwell
was now an injured soldier who sought
refuge in the pool at walter reed i
jumped in the pool for the first time
after missing my leg and i didn't have
to wear a prosthetic leg right and i got
in and it was just like this freeing
feeling it's almost like i forgot as i
was missing my leg i randomly loved the
smell of chlorine and i think i probably
got in the pool like days after i heard
about the paralympics it was just kind
of this like natural fit and decided
that i was gonna give it a shot in the
sport of swimming it was 2004. four
years later
you end up in the paralympics swimming i
know it was great
i was a total long shot to make the team
so i'd always been an athlete but
thinking about how amazing it would be
to you know represent a country i
defended over in iraq wear that team usa
uniform on the world's biggest athletic
stage i mean showing the world that i
wasn't sitting in a dark room with the
lights off but i was out there living it
and seeing what i could do she competed
in three swimming events in beijing in
2008 and served as team usa's flag
bearer at the closing ceremony this flag
that i am so passionate about sold out
stadium i mean looking back it was what
was meant to be you wanted to serve the
country and you were it was it was a
different way than what you thought very
much
i think you know the military and the
paralympics it's a very different
uniform of course but it's they
represent such similar things i mean
defending representing it's all for the
same country
stockwell's dreams didn't end there
apparently for you it wasn't enough
to just go to a paralympics as a swimmer
let's completely switch up sports now
yeah and let's try to be a triathlete
at the next game i used to think
triathletes were crazy because it's like
you swim you bike in a run like on the
same day and like who wants to do that
but i knew how to swim i had gotten a
running blade i had a bike i'm like you
know what let's give it a shot but
before the rio games she decided to as
she put it have a kid real quick
not that there's anything quite another
challenge into the mix
coming back from having a baby and your
entire body changed my son was born in
2014 right the games were in 2016. i had
to qualify in 2015. so like coming back
from that was the hard i'd like to say
it was harder than losing my life was it
really
it was so difficult because your body
changes everything changes it's not just
your body change that you're trying to
deal with it's your life it's your time
juggling things but at the same time it
kind of gave me that sense of purpose
too and i was named the 2016 paralympic
team for rio thanks it was great
yes yes
don't bet against you because you didn't
just make the team
right stockwell competed in the
inaugural paralympic triathlon in rio in
2016.
her race was on 9 11.
any day that could have been it was
september 11th putting that usa uniform
on that race was about so much more than
me it was about those who given the
ultimate sacrifice every swim stroke
bike pedal run step was going to be for
them and
crossing the finish line i got a bronze
medal
my teammates got gold and silver usa
sweep september 11th on the podium three
american flags our national anthem i
mean it is a moment that will go down as
one of the greatest moments in my life a
great moment in a storied life that
revolves around service and patriotism
there's all these like metaphoric
roadside bombs that i think happen in
all of our lives and it's kind of how
you perceive them we have the choice and
how we
get through them and we can choose to
accept them to surround ourselves with a
team of people that love us that care
about us to believe in ourselves and
little by little take those small
successes every day and it's amazing
what it can end up to be and it's not
perfect it's never perfect life is not
perfect never never
if that's not enough perseverance
stockwell was in a bike crash last month
broke her back uh transfer or her pros
vertebrae i should say sorry still she
considers herself lucky she says she
could have been paralyzed instead she
has an opportunity to in her words make
it to the other side and we've seen her
do that before she will be competing
on friday what a spiritual unbelievable
woman mother of two great example she's
irrepressible friday she'll be competing
on friday yeah no i'd love to have a
baby right quick
that it was more difficult than losing
her leg